you know it's interesting I look back on
some season one and I realize that the
character is pretty much the same as
when I started him I think that he has
evolved as a person over the last seven
years and that's been an interesting
thing I think he's not so much Michael's
sycophant anymore he's pretty separate
and independent from Michael they've had
some falling outs he's no longer
interlocked with the character of
Michael Scott
so he's matured he's more confident he's
more socially confident he's more
confident from women he's become a
little bit more of the alpha male kind
of testing his his limits in the office
in the workplace and I think that's been
interesting but the character in terms
of the acting is really the same I think
from season one
I would hire Dwight yes I would in a
heartbeat he would do anything I could
hire him for any job imaginable and he
would he would morph himself to the task